the whole sort of atheist critique of
religion doesn't really address Buddhism
insofar as Buddhism is established
really as a science of the mind it's
based on observation of the mind and
everything that Buddha taught can be
empirically verified through your own
experience in other words you can test
it actually I think it's a very
interesting science because you're the
scientist you're not just reading about
what other scientists have done and you
know confirmed and so forth like that
but you yourself are the experimenter
you experiment with your own mind what
Buddha basically said is that we can
understand through our own experience
that happiness comes from inner peace
and we can explore that in our own
experience and see well that's true
happiness does come from inner peace and
maybe even more importantly we can also
then establish I have the capacity for
inner peace in my own mind in fact we
might even say that through through
training the mind through practicing
meditation you can see that it's
actually not difficult all we need to do
is learn to let go of our unhappy
thoughts and our mind automatically
becomes peaceful so in other words you
don't like make your mind peaceful you
just have to let go of you're unhappy or
unhappy thoughts your angry thoughts
your anxious thoughts and what happens
through that is that you then begin to
experience a sense of peace a deep inner
peace and you can verify that through
your own experience and through that you
get in touch then with your own
potential for peace or other virtuous
Minds like love or compassion or joy or
kindness generosity in other words you
can verify it through your own
experimentation that that's the case
what we then discover is that the mind
has this incredible capacity for
profound peace or we might say for
limitless love for limit
kindness that's where I find some fault
with the you know as your because you're
calling it the New Atheism simply
because I don't think they are paying
enough attention to the science of the
mind through which we can establish so
to speak an alt alternative science but
it's equally empirically verifiable that
there is a spiritual dimension to our
being that you can discover through your
own practice in fact that there is this
yeah we might say a a divine element to
our nature because we discover that the
mind has this capacity for limitless
love limitless compassion limitless joy